mon petit lot adoré je voudrais mourir
un jour que tu m'aimes
je voudrais être beau pour que tu
m'aimes
je voudrais être fort pour que tu
m'aimes je voudrais être jeune
je ne pour que tu m'aimes
je voudrais que la guerre recommence à
pour que tu m'aimes je voudrais que tu
sois mon cœur
pour te sentir toujours en moi
je voudrais que tu sois le paradis ou
l'enfer selon le lieu au chat
je voudrais que tu sois un petit garçon
pour être ton précepteur
je voudrais que tu sois la nuit pour
nous aimer dans les ténèbres
je voudrais que tu sois ma vie
pour être par toi seul
je voudrais que tu sois un obus poche
pour me tuer d'un sou d'un amour